[Music]
Courtney says no here at the VTT Awards
pre-party where we just talked to the
CEO of BT she teased some surprises for
Sunday night and we got an update on
Beyonce and jay-z after welcoming their
twins big nominations for Beyonce yes
who would be accepting her award if she
were to win I don't know but I doubt
that she'll show up I think she's busy
right now and congratulations to Beyonce
and jay-z and Blue Ivy Emmy what two
great additions to their family so we're
really excited for them for she was a
surprise performer here last year and
that was amazing but we're going to give
her a little time off this year she
reached out and how are they doing from
what I hear everyone's doing fine but
Leslie Jones told ET she won't be
sending B and J a gift for the twins I
mean me and Beyonce don't know each
other like that I mean I love BAE but I
ain't bout to send no gifts she got
enough money she tell her to send me
something what's the theme of this award
show because you do so many BT Awards
every year yeah
well I think the theme has kind of been
set by Leslie Jones
she says this is her coming home party
and she started on comic view and so
she's been very vocal about this so I
think it's going to feel like a family
event this weekend
and we wanted to be joyous and we want
to celebrate the artists and people in
our community that are doing wonderful
things you know we're just looking to
have a moment to escape that was a
little tease to something Oh kind of
slip that in there so all right so we
have some big tributes happening and
escape new edition are going to be doing
something who is actually going to be
doing those tributes so I know escape is
coming back together so it's going to be
a reunion and new addition here you know
we're going to have the littles back in
the bigs and from the cast and the group
itself so I don't know who else is
involved they keep some secrets for me
but it's going to be great and then of
course we're honoring chance the rapper
with the humanitarian award so I'm so
excited about that because he's been so
active and so vocal and we need to pay
tribute to young people especially like
him
[Music]
you